[Musique]
l'arrivée du printemps et des beaux
jours semblent comme réveiller les
fontaines du parc de versailles
après une pause de cinq mois l'eau
jaillit à nouveau dans un jardin
spectaculaire de 77 hectares imaginé il
ya 350 ans par le roi soleil et qui
éblouit toujours autant les yeux des
visiteurs et ce grillage
c'est vraiment impressionnant et
magnifique tout le travail qui a été
réalisé vaut le coup les gens du monde
entier peuvent venir et apprécier le
spectacle
c'est une vraie bénédiction les grandes
eaux musicales parfait endroit pour se
balader et profitez en musique du décor
boisé du château de versailles
au total 55 fontaine sont à découvrir
et parmi les nouveautés cette année le
bassin des enfants de récré en 1709
elle aura encore plus de sens si
quelques semaines quand son écrin de
verdure va littéralement lui faire un
panneau arrière un fond vert
on dirait autour d'elle elle va soudain
ressortir encore mieux il ya vraiment
cette pensée du début à la fin
c'est une des salles de plus du château
le château de versailles il ya de
l'intérieur il ya de l'extérieur traités
avec le même soin et peut-être à
l'époque avec le même budget tellement
les fontaines coûter cher
la réussite de ce concert d'eau et de
verdure serait impossible sans eux les
fontainiers ils sont trés arpenter les
sols et les sous sols du château depuis
le xviiie siècle la méthode reste la
même avec une clé à lire j'ai en fait de
poser ma clé de manette dessus pour
pouvoir tourner la clé qui permet
d'ouvrir les vannes et ainsi faire
jaillir l'eau dans la fontaine des
enfants doré c'est l'aboutissement déjà
du travail qu'on a eu en amont pour
préparer les fontaines pour justement le
spectacle des grandes eaux
faire plaisir aux gens et voilà les
perpétuer aussi un geste ancestral plus
de 70 représentations des grandes eaux
musicales sont prévues jusqu'au 29
octobre prochain
[Musique]